I want to take you back in time my
friends I want to give you a warm memory
something that you can take and press to
your bosom and feel good at night and it
is a story from Snopes Snopes I know I
can already hear the gasps from the
crowd did U.S gas prices drop below two
dollars under Trump they want you to
forget gas was under two dollars when
Trump was in office one Twitter user
posted
claim national gas price averages for
regular fuel dropped below two dollars
per gallon during U.S president Trump's
term in office Snopes has determined
this to be true in early October 2022
received increase from readers who asked
if it is true the national average gas
price fell under two dollars per gallon
that's right a dollar eighty four per
gallon in April 2020. they do want you
to forget it because right now as you
are being squeezed out with a near four
dollar average across the country and it
going up Joe Biden is desperately
begging Saudi Arabia to postpone it just
long enough for them to win the midterms
so while that is going on and Joe Biden
is being is facing well we'll see if
there's any real consequences but as
long as we're talking about it and
calling him out while he's facing that
news story I want to make sure everybody
remembers guests dropped below two
dollars under Trump yeah no wait wait
I'm sorry I'm sorry there's here's the
uh
I want to give a shout out because they
did change the article when I tweeted
this story out the claim said national
gas prices for regular fuel dropped
below two dollars per gallon during U.S
president Donald Trump's first term in
office
and I tweeted that screenshot stick sex
and Hammer responded pointing to first
term and then said they know
they're implying Trump's going to win
he's going to come back in 2024. well
this definitely gives them an
opportunity to do so and as you guys
know I'm not a big fan of Donald Trump
but under his administration imported
oil dropped by 25 he did allow
exploration he did allow production
which brought more oil on the World
Market and with more oil the demand of
it went down and the price of it went
down as well so when you look at those
kind of policies they did make a huge
impact because when you have cheap
energy you have an ability for human
beings to to progress and on that marker
Donald Trump has something to stand on
and brag about since of course this
Administration is doing the opposite of
that and Wrecking havoc on our financial
system deliberately it's funny it's like
we were a net exporter of fuel weren't
we you know in 2020 and uh gas price was
dirt cheap and now we're desperately
importing and gas is very expensive
how's that and it's it's just a series
of self-inflicted problems I mean the
border is a self-inflicted problem the
energy costs or a self-inflicted problem
problem
all of the money we're spending in
Ukraine is largely I mean obviously it's
to some degree a Putin inflicted problem
but it's largely a self-inflicted
problem I want to pause there and and
put a note on that Putin did start this
war but the U.S but the United States
choosing to be involved is a
self-inflicted problem that's right yes
absolutely and and to be involved
without any scrutiny without any end
goal without any uh how did I'm sorry
how does this happen there's no
declaration of war how is it that we get
roped into sending billions of dollars
100 billion what's the number so far we
didn't vote on this Congress didn't did
what did Congress declare war and say
that we are we're able to to do this the
40 billion they voted on and but
somebody yeah the drawdown packages and
all of those things those don't come
from Congress at all this is This Is War
this is providing intelligence and
resources to fight Russia
and what they don't need to declare war
in this capacity
we're going to be dragged into it now I
mean if if they're allowed to get away
with this then there never will be I
mean there hasn't been they've not
declared war since what World War II
declaration of war has kind of become
one of those dead letters it's sort of a
nicety they're reducing the Constitution
to really the Roberts Rules of Order
like the process related things of like
how many people get to serve in Congress
what their ages of Eligibility are we
take those things very seriously
enumerated power is not very much
I'm looking at the average crude oil
price and it it's true in April 2020 it
was 21 bucks uh but in like January of
2020 it was 61. so it dropped massively
and then the pandemic struck and then it
would start just to scale back up up to
100 and so from like 21 in April 2020 to
116. six times five times the amount in
June and it's got it's got to be
correlating with inflation which is also
self-inflicted I think if you look at
the average of his presidency it was
like two dollars and thirty cents or
something so even if we were to take out
that that you know that low point
it was still better under Trump and it's
simple when Trump is is is green
lighting energy exploration and
production
speculation on these things are that
there's going Supply will meet demand
and so the price stabilizes when Joe
Biden comes in and starts axing permits
and shutting down pipelines speculation
is that we will not have a supply to
meet demand and the price skyrockets
just from speculation alone not to
mention we do have now A reduced Supply
and then we we go you know Biden goes to
Saudi Arabia and says we desperately
need production to go up and they say no
so what does Biden do he drains the
Strategic petroleum Reserve he's like
imagine I want you to imagine this way
your roommate quits his job
no longer making any money and you're
like bro you need a job no no no don't
worry I'm gonna ask my mom my mom will
give me money my mom's gonna my mom's
good she's gonna give me money and then
every time
his mom says no he goes into your rainy
day fund and pulls cash and says no no
don't worry don't worry it's just we've
got to pay the rent you know but but my
mom will come through and now the rainy
day jar is almost empty
I I'm thinking about like the Strategic
oil Reserve is that the low it's it's
one of its lowest points in in decades
so now you have to think about it you
know this was predominantly I I believe
correct me if I'm wrong was created
because of World War II just so the
United States has enough oil and energy
to actually fight a war so with these
levels being low we're not really at
preparedness levels from from a lot of
an analysts perspectives to be able to
fight a war now if there is a war now
we're kind of stuck in a very bad
situation that's what exactly I was
thinking is it seems like whoever's in
charge in command which is obviously the
commander-in-chief the President Joe
Biden uh doesn't has this like illusion
that we're invulnerable or something
like the way they surrendered in
Afghanistan and like let all those
people die and let all that
infrastructure however many billions of
dollars worth of uh equipment left over
for the Taliban without you think
there's no consequences because we're
America No One's Gonna attack us we're
fine like you can't just cut off the oil
that fuels the Jets and the bombers and
the tanks and the planes and the
factories that make the steel and and
the the Plastics that we use for all of
our phones and our roads and our like
and and expect that no one's going to
attack Us in the meantime while we don't
have a supply that's when countries get
attacked is when they're when they're at
their weakest you need a defensive
mechanism in place well at the same time
he was doing all of this too he was
attacking domestic oil producers to
attacking domestic energy producers and
saying that they're the reason that
prices are up and it's price gouging and
he's really done this with with every
vaguely inflation related topic I mean
all politicians to some extent do this
but Biden's really Brazen everything
going wrong in the economy is some
external factor that is outside of his
control he has nothing to do with it
everything that goes right in the
economy is a direct result of his policy
it's it's price hike if you remember
he's been saying it's just transitory
it's it's great that it's here it's
actually good that it's here I actually
started my video off today with a
compilation of Biden within the last two
years saying hey you know inflation it's
not here it's transitory it's crazy and
you just see the progression progression
of it and now we are here with new
inflation numbers that should terrify
people as of course these are
manipulated numbers and the real life
numbers are a lot more daunting that of
course aren't really published aren't
really talked about but should be if you
live long enough everything is
transitory that's right yes life is
transitory yeah so this whole War don't
worry it's transitory yeah for 20 some
odd years we got to experience
Afghanistan amazing well I want to add
it to uh to Joe Biden he is uh he is
what's the right way to phrase this he
has accomplished what his detractors
thought he would accomplish but boy did
he do it tenfold and did it faster than
people expected I mean I knew war was
coming I was saying like look you vote
for buying we're gonna get War I didn't
know it was going to be world war three
wow you know well beyond my expectations
Biden you did it it's like uh it's like
bowling a perfect game of gutter balls
it's like well you you have consistency
there but we didn't think you'd do that
bad there you go yeah I remember when
Biden first got in I'm like the
probability and chances of us going
towards high now 100 in Ukraine and it's
been absolutely true now you know this
leads us to kind of question is it
because he's a bad leader is it because
he's a failed leader is it because he's
an incompetent leader or is this a part
of a bigger ruse a bigger plan in order
to bring something else in that will of
course profit and benefit off of these
problems that are being deliberately
caused right now it could be both
because I do think he is incompetent
well based on the Afghanistan surrender
that is the most incompetent use of the
American Military I've ever heard of to
lose that war that we are winning to
give up to the Taliban and let them take
over like that I I gotta disagree with
you I think that was an act of pure
competence it was intentional you do not
accidentally abandon an Air Force Base
in the middle of the night that can't be
an accident no it's one thing it was
intentional which is like plus the
United States has the United States has
military protocol to blow up and to
literally send in fighter jets to to
destroy U.S equipment before they go
into enemies hands they failed to do
that with Isis in Northern Iraq before
Isis got all the Humvee vehicles and
they failed to do that here in
Afghanistan as well
so when I when I say it was competence
it wasn't that they made a bad call it
was the right call for exactly what they
wanted to happen they know what they're
doing you don't accidentally say okay
everybody at 3am quickly flee and the
Riders and looters come and take
everything that just doesn't happen yeah
I would think it wouldn't nobody in
their right mind would do something like
that and not only that they could have
done the evacuations through the
Fortified Air Force Base it could have
taken eight months they could have told
the Taliban to suck it we're leaving
when we're leaving it doesn't matter
what day we told you it's War deal with
it air support got pulled all of a
sudden the the air superiority was gone
Taliban started rushing in Afghans
security forces were getting we're
getting massacred yeah that was I I view
that all as intentional well in the one
foreign policy question that Biden has
been right about in his entire career
was that the U.S Western supported
Afghan government was fake that it was
corrupt it was fake it wasn't real
and yet he premised at least publicly
his entire withdrawal strategy on that
government being able to hold long
enough for everybody to get out when his
own predictions had said that there was
just without U.S support that government
couldn't exist yeah especially the air
support I mean they were heavily reliant
on the logistics that the United States
was providing and then without the
logistics they were empty it was like a
a bunch of people that didn't know who
was where it was a Warren Zevon
government send Lawyers Guns and Money
And if you don't send those things there
is no government thanks for checking out
this segment from the timcast IRL
podcast but if you want to check out the
full show live tune in Monday through
Friday at 8 pm and if you want more
special access content head over to
timcast.com and become a member your
membership helps sustain this company
keep our journalists employed makes this
show happen and you will get access to
exclusive members only segments of the
timcast IRL podcast and there's a
massive library to checkout so again go
to timcast.com or tune in Monday through
Friday at 8pm and we'll see you all
there